so where we left off in the last video
benjamin franklin was born to a period
who's a tenth son to a puritan father in
boston and he eventually ends up working
for his brother as an apprentice at age
12 but then runs away at 17. right he
runs away he had written the silence
do-good essays his brother had caught
him
writing these essays under the pseudonym
silence do good and franklin didn't want
to remain an apprentice even though he
was bound to do so so he runs away in
the night time he gets on a boat in uh
boston sails uh originally to new york
and after a few days decides to continue
on to philadelphia going up the road up
the philadelphia bay the delaware bay
and then into the river and onto the
market street wharf of philadelphia
and there's a famous scene of him
already 15 years old 19 17 years old
bedraggled wet
he has only a few coins in his pocket
when he arrives at the wharf he gives
one of the coins to the boatmen as a tip
he says you know when you're really poor
you don't want people to know you're
poor so you pretend to be a little bit
richer and there it is franklin already
caring about his public relations uh and
caring about just sort of being a
typical american sort of saying i don't
want to look like i'm poor i'm going to
be a generous guy
and him marching up market street with
uh he buys three puffy rolls and he's
all wet and bedraggled
he passes a doorway and there's a 15
year old girl named deborah reed
and she sort of laughs at him thinks he
makes a ridiculous looking figure
you know we know this because
years later when he was 65 years old he
writes his autobiography and there's the
scene in it of him arriving in
philadelphia and i think it's the best
and certainly the most famous scene in
autobiographical literature which is ben
franklin's arrival in philadelphia and
you see him discussing his arrival and
as you look at the manuscript of the
autobiography you see he writes in the
fact that his wife you know who must
have told him this later said hey i was
laughing at you and thought you made a
ridiculous figure and later on franklin
writes in in the third draft that he's
doing of the autobiography as i
certainly did so he
being sort of self-aware and
self-deprecating but also very proud
because here he is saying rags to riches
i was in rags i was bedraggled my even
the person i ended up marrying was
laughing at me and then i became a great
success and pretty immediately he wants
to marry her but it doesn't work right
he decides to propose marriage to her
her father was a tradesman you know a
pretty successful merchant in
philadelphia but benjamin franklin first
of all he's 17 and he was truly a 17
year old meaning he may have been very
wise and could write very well but he
had a lot of adventures let us say and
at one point he has to go to england to
get
the uh printing material the typesets
and the printing presses that he needs
to become a printer he wants to be a
printer but you have to need equipment
right he didn't have equipment he was
working for somebody else who was a
printer and he wanted to start up a
rival print shop and somebody said i'll
stake you i'll give you the money you go
to london and you buy the press but the
guy who was going to stake him ends up
you know pulling out or you know doesn't
really stake him and franklin arrives in
london with no money
so he works for almost two years in
london to make enough money to buy the
printing equipment
while he's over there first of all he's
having a good time he has many
girlfriends and you know maybe writing a
letter every now and then old to his uh
young friend deborah back in
philadelphia but she ends up getting
married she doesn't wait for him
and it's a real mess because she gets
married franklin comes back from london
and then her husband disappears
so she's not really divorced
but she's not really
you know single
and she's not really married and so they
eventually enter into a common law
marriage because they couldn't get
married in the church because she was
technically still married and he
as i said was having fun as a young you
know 20 year old
and he had his own illegitimate child a
son named william
but unlike a lot of the people at that
period who had illegitimate children he
immediately took responsibility he
decides he's going to raise william
himself and so deborah is not only
willing to enter into common law
marriage but also help raise his son
william franklin so this is pretty
especially for that period in time i
mean on both sides this
she i guess was officially married in
the eyes of the church
but that's why they had to get kind of a
purely legal marriage
and then he has an illegitimate child
right returns and
you know and this isn't this is in 1730
so he's still a fairly young man and
she's even younger he's 24 she's like
it's 22 at this point right right and uh
he you know it was a somewhat
unconventional type of family and
throughout his life he had that it's
hard to know what to make of the
relationship between deborah reed
who never as far as we can tell and i've
researched this a lot
never left philadelphia probably never
spent the night more than four blocks
from market street whereas you'll see
from franklin's life he's in london he's
in paris he's in boston he goes up and
down the coast of america during the
postal system and yet they have a very
sort of friendly even loving
relationship but not what we would call
a normal
conventional marriage huh fascinating
and so and this is you know he's trying
to establish himself now he's come he
comes back he he's got some money saved
up he's got the equipment and this is
when he really starts to establish
himself as the i guess the benjamin
franklin most people remember well he
becomes one of our first successful
small business owners and soon it
becomes a big business he has a print
shop in philadelphia and if you have a
print shop you end up needing some
content to print in order to be good so
he starts a newspaper which was the
pennsylvania gazette unlike the other
newspapers there are a lot of other
newspapers in this small town maybe nine
or ten of them but one of them is
affiliated with the anglicans and others
affiliated with the quakers another with
the proprietors they were called the
penn family who owned most of the land
and franklin decides to start an
independent newspaper with a spunky
independent very
sort of freedom-loving american voice
and he writes them with a lot of
pseudonyms again in his newspaper you
know writes stories under different
people's uh you know names including
polly baker or womany invents
who tells the story of how she had had
illegitimate children but raised them
all so he gets into sort of the politics
a little bit of social justice social
justice a bit but done with a real sense
of humor as polly baker is standing in
front of the court saying hey i'm doing
good for this colony and by the way some
of you in the court are the reason i
have these illegitimate children so it's
a very funny fictional piece but it's
got a little social justice under
current the other thing he does because
he wants a successful print job is he
uh needs something you know books to
print and he realizes that printing the
bible is not a really uh smart idea
because people buy the bible just once
in their life maybe twice
he should print an almanac because
people buy an almanac
every year so in 1733 he starts what's
called poor richard's almanac and just
to take a step back here i mean i
actually remember
almanacs and i'm assuming they're still
printed but
i would guess some of the younger
listeners to this will have no idea of
what an almanac is imagine the world
wide web but in a pocketbook form it
came out every year it told you the
population of every city it predicted
the weather it told you what the weather
was like the year before it
gave you the horoscopes and the where
the moon phases and the sunrises would
be but it also had wonderful little
lessons told you how to remove stains
from fabrics
when tim berners-lee invites invents the
world wide web he says because he
remembered an almanac an almanac of the
same period has been franklin's poor
richest almanac that was called inquire
within for everything so the first name
of the web was inquire it was a system
written to be an almanac but do it
electronically and why did he why isn't
it not called ben franklin's almanac ben
franklin very often as i said wrote
under a pseudonym sometimes he did it to
disguise and be anonymous just like we
invent pseudonyms when we're on you know
twitter maybe or something uh on the
other hand everybody knew who poor
richard was uh it was sold at ben
franklin's print shop everybody knew he
was poor richard saunders but he gave
him a way to poke fun
be humorous poor richard saunders even
pokes fun at his printer meaning pokemon
is ben franklin uh saying he wants all
these rattling traps he needs to make
money out of them and so he's using me
to make money that sort of thing and we
even get some of the famous old maxims
because franklin liked to put in the
margin of his almanac
poor richard's sayings and you may
remember some of them
you know penny said he saved is a penny
earned and early to bad early to rise
makes a man healthy wealthy and wise and
there were really about 150 of these
over the years that become quite famous
some of which he adopted from other
people's writings
but he just knew how to make him clever
and pithy and becomes the most
successful almanac ever printed in
america
thousands and thousands of copies so he
ends up franchising other people in
other cities to create print shops to do
portugal richard's almanac and one of
the coolest things he does as a media
guy is he has the
printing press he has the content he
decides he needs a distribution system
so he helps create the american colonial
postal system to tie together all of his
print shops and to send the newspapers
back and forth and to help the printing
businesses of all of his friends and
apprentices and relatives up and down
the coast of the colonies be tied
together this is no small thing you're
saying he's constructing the postal
system the us colonial postal system is
primarily brought together by benjamin
franklin as a printer in philadelphia in
order to tie together the various
printing shops and the colonies that
were usually run by his friends and
relatives and to distribute the content
like poor richard's almanac fascinating